why was melissa roush's appearance as a
marvel superhero quite so short and why
did she jump over to the dc universe
soon after keep watching during its
12-season run the big bang theory was
beloved by audiences all over the world
the series became something of an award
magnet as the years went on netting
several primetime emmys among other
notable prizes it famously thrust nerd
culture into the mainstream which no
other sitcom had ever done with such
unapologetic aplomb of course there was
also the comedy's stable of characters
and the actors who played them that
drove the series for the duration of its
run by the time the big bang theory left
the small screen in 2019 its main cast
had grown to include eight names jim
parsons played sheldon cooper kaylee
cuoco starred as penny teller johnny
galecki was leonard hofstadter mayam
bialik played amy farah fowler simon
hellberg starred as howard wallace kunal
neher was raj kuthrapali and melissa
rausch played bernadette rostinkowski
not only was the big bang theory steady
work for its stars they were compensated
handsomely for their efforts too
nevertheless a well-paying job didn't
stop some of its stars from exploring
other creative avenues in the case of
melissa roush she even visited the
marvel universe for a spell during her
big bang theory tenure but you might not
realize who she played two years after
the character's arrival in the marvel
cinematic universe in which he was
portrayed by paul rudd ant-man became
the lead of his own animated series
simply titled ant-man the series of
shorts saw the titular shrinking hero
stand toe-to-toe against a variety of
villains pulled from his comic book
counterparts rogues gallery including
yellowjacket josh keaton of voltron
legendary defender and hercules fame
took on the show's lead voice role but
his two-dimensional take on scott lang
couldn't save the world from evil on its
own alongside dee bradley baker's hank
pym bernadette rostinkowski actor
melissa roush joined the fray as hope
pym also known as the wasp fans of the
marvel cinematic universe are already
familiar with her character who is
portrayed by evangeline lilly in the
original 2015 movie and the 2018 film
ant-man and the wasp in those movies her
character is named hope van dyne bearing
the surname of her mother janet van dyne
who wore the wasp suit in a previous
life lily's take on the character is a
distinct entity from her comic book
progenitor in several key ways roush's
wasp meanwhile retains the name hope pym
from the comic book source material thus
maintaining some characteristics that
fell by the wayside when the character
was adapted for the mcu sadly for fans
of the actor and the wasp character
alike roush only appeared in two of the
ant-man cartoon's six episodes in the
first alien invasion the episode opens
with ant-man bragging to the wasp about
a prior mission when an alarm goes off
in his lab signaling that an armada of
tiny aliens is approaching ant-man and
the wasp then team up and promptly stop
them in her second appearance on the
show in an episode titled not a date
hank and hope are enjoying a day out
with one another out of costume when the
villainous whirlwind attacks that's no
ordinary tornado it's whirlwind one of
my dad's enemies fortunately the two
heroes are prepared for such an occasion
and quickly suit up allowing them to
fight their adversary ant-man and the
wasp alternately use their growth and
shrinking abilities to take them down
all the while arguing about whether or
not their outing constitutes a date in
the end roush's time as the wasp
amounted to a rather short run as the
marvel comics mainstay thankfully she
ended up with a much more significant
spotlight under the dc comics banner
when she got to voice fan favorite
harley quinn in the 2017 batman and
harley quinn animated feature all in all
melissa roush's marvel legacy doesn't
come anywhere close to that of
present-day mcu staple evangeline lilly
but at least she got to voice the
character for a little while perhaps
someday she'll return to the world of
marvel in a more substantial part
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you